[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec kurtar rappeur chanteur
indépendant des Yvelines bonjour bonjour
alors que vous êtes fait connaître du
grand public grâce à une chanson elle
s'appelle trap et elle porte simplement
sur la ville où vous avez étudié c'est
un vrai hymne à l'amour qui a été fait
alors que la commune était au cœur de de
plusieurs polémiques est-ce que ce sont
ces polémiques justement qui vous ont
poussé à écrire une chanson sur la ville
alors ce morceau il a toute une histoire
effectivement j'ai étudié dans la ville
de Trappes au Lycée Henri Matisse et en
fait ça faisait déjà un moment que je
faisais des petites scènes notamment
pour des associations à la salle JB
Clément des tremplins à la Merise et
quand il y a eu ces polémiques en fait
il y a une habitante de la ville de
Trappes qui se nomme Houria qui qui m'a
demandé de venir
écrire un texte parce qu'en fait l'idée
c'est qu'on demander beaucoup de
personnes qui n'étaient pas forcément
issues de trappes et qui disait pas
forcément du bien de la ville et moi bon
je ne suis pas de trap même mais
j'habite à Montigny j'ai une attache
particulière pour la ville et l'image
que certaines personnes ont c'est pas la
mienne donc j'ai décidé voilà avec ce
petit projet avec Houria de faire ce
morceau ça allait assez vite elle m'en a
parlé j'ai écrit le lendemain une
semaine plus tard on faisait le clip
alors justement ça a fait ça fait un
buzz même de grand média en ont parlé
est-ce que vous estimez justement que
cette engagement pour la ville de
Trappes a réussi à à changer cette image
que les gens qui sont extérieurs à la
ville ont malheureusement il y aura
toujours des des préjugés il y aura
toujours des gens qui qui ne feront pas
l'effort entre guillemets de d'aller
chercher plus loin mais ça c'est pour
énormément de sujets après
je pense que c'était juste important
trap en fait c'est ça peut représenter
n'importe quelle ville un peu
stigmatisée on a entendu aussi des
reportages sur roubaix
il y a des villes en France où tout
n'est pas rose le but c'est pas possible
de dire mais non mais tout va bien on
est dans un monde de bisounours pas du
tout mais c'est de dire que oui il y a
des villes peut-être un petit peu plus
sensible que d'autres mais qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on peut bien évidemment
montrer du doigt les choses qui ne vont
pas mais on peut aussi montrer les
doigts tout ce qui se passe de bien il y
a plein de gens dans ces villes qui font
énormément et je voulais justement
souligner cela et j'espère que certains
ont pu se dire que effectivement c'est
pas forcément ce qu'il pensait votre
votre carrière émergente ne s'arrête pas
tout ça à Trappes à ce titre vous êtes
un artiste engagé pour défendre et vous
exprimer sur des sujets qui vous
touchent et vous tiennent à cœur en mars
vous avez sorti un single qui s'appelle
petit en mars 2021 on va écouter un
court extrait on en parle juste après
tu vivras dans une
femme et virale les obstacles sur ton
chemin
[Musique]
tu ne seras personne libre sur ton
visage
tu dessineras toute sorte de paysages
tu seras toujours à penser au lendemain
alors petit à découvrir sur votre chaîne
Youtube curta MLB quel est le message
que vous avez souhaité transmettre à
travers ce morceau alors c'est un
message un peu autobiographique c'est un
morceau où je retrace tout simplement
mon parcours en fait il faut savoir que
effectivement il y avait eu le morceau
au trap qui avait fait pas mal parlé
mais en novembre 2018 j'avais des aussi
sorti un morceau sur la Kery James qui
avait fait lui aussi beaucoup parler
même presque encore plus donc du coup il
m'est arrivé plein de belles choses et
en fait ce morceau petit c'est le
dernier titre de mon premier projet qui
se nomme 7 K8 qui est sorti le 11
décembre 2020 et du coup c'était
important pour moi de clôturer ce projet
avec un morceau un peu autobiographique
et un peu porteur d'espoir avec de se
dire bah voilà tu as encore plein de
choses à accomplir mais tu as déjà
réussi à faire tout ça et ça peut être
une fierté justement pourquoi vous
adressez aux jeunes curta est-ce qu'il y
avait un message important à adresser
alors la fois jeune curta mais peut-être
aussi aux jeunes qui des fois ont envie
de se lancer dans la musique et qui
n'osent pas et ben voilà c'est ce que
voilà quand je disais surtout c'est que
de base moi j'ai commencé avec rien ça
veut dire que
bon mes parents n'écoutaient pas
forcément de rap j'avais pas de grand
frère qui m'a mis le pied dedans j'ai
tout fait tout seul j'ai commencé à
écrire très jeune et c'était important
pour moi oui d'être un peu ce message
d'espoir de dire que quand on a ce rêve
il faut y aller il faut aller jusqu'au
bout et moi j'ai découvert l'arabe je me
suis noyé dedans et ça m'a jamais lâché
et comme je suis en plus de ça animateur
en périscolaire je coach parce que bon
pour l'instant le rap comme je suis
indépendant je fais tout tout seul donc
faut payer tout ça et j'ai vraiment une
approche particulière avec la ça me
tient énormément à coeur et du coup le
clip de petit justement a été tourné
dans l'école dans laquelle je travaille
donc il y a tout un message derrière en
disant les jeunes les enfants vous avez
des rêves faut y aller et vous avez été
absent quelques mois mais vous êtes
revenu en force le 18 novembre dernier
avec un nouveau single alors ça
s'appelle le coupe du monde au Qatar
pourquoi ce titre alors c'est vrai que
du coup en décembre 2021 j'avais fait la
première partie de Kery James à trappe
justement donc entre Kery James trap la
boucle était bouclée ensuite j'ai fait
mon premier concert officiel à la salle
Jacques Brel à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
donc c'était un événement très très fort
et il a fallu du coup un petit peu que
je me vide l'esprit que je reparte un
petit peu à zéro donc j'ai disparu
pendant plusieurs mois entre guillemets
disparu mais je travaillais dans l'ombre
et je suis revenu avec ce fameux morceau
Coupe du Monde au Qatar l'idée était de
revenir aussi avec un morceau un petit
peu
un morceau puissant un morceau fort avec
un titre accrocheur comme j'avais pu le
faire justement avec Kery James trap
mais l'idée c'est toujours de véhiculer
des messages derrière c'est pas juste de
rebondir sur un fait d'actualité pour
chercher le buzz et aussi pour dire ce
que je pense et cet événement bon
malheureusement j'ai appris un peu trop
tard parce que c'est il y a 10 ans qu'il
fallait bouger
quand l'événement est passé et c'est
vrai que de toute façon qu'on est
regardé ou pas l'événement ça n'a pas
changé grand-chose mais
quand j'ai appris tout l'envers du décor
j'avais cette envie un peu de donner mon
opinion alors je reste assez
simple on va dire dans dans mon texte je
fais juste dénoncer ce qu'on sait en
fait en parlant de ces pauvres
travailleurs migrants qui sont morts en
parlant de la corruption après je vais
pas plus loin je suis pas dans les
polémiques cathares enfin moi moi c'est
plutôt
entre guillemets je voulais dénoncer cet
événement et voilà il y a encore des
événements prévus des des JO en plein
désert fait pour moi il y a un i quoi
c'est pas possible surtout avec tout ce
qu'on tout ce qu'on connaît
environnementalement parlant
donc j'avais envie de parler ça et aussi
j'en ai profité dans ce morceau de faire
un premier couplet un peu égo trip en
disant je suis de retour vu que ça
faisait quand même dis-moi que j'avais
rien sorti il y avait cette idée de de
revenir et de voilà de de bousculer un
peu les codes justement écouter un
extrait de de votre morceau Coupe du
Monde au Qatar et on poursuit juste
après arrivé fracasse de votre
traumatisé c'est sur moi qu'il faut
miser fedature on vient viser quel est
le monde c'est fulgurante personne va
m'utiliser ou veut déstabiliser on vise
gros concert mais pas dans stade
climatisé oh rapide comme Sonic
dictionnaire comme Sony du bon rap
bientôt
10 la musique moi obligé pas le temps ma
jolie malin comme un hobbit je viens
même une phobie j'emmerde tout leur
lobby leur texte et les Toby sur bulles
en pas mobile ouragan dans le showbiz
premier couplet et gotrip ça fait
plaisir pour un retour différent flots
différents styles le rap et moi il y a
trop d'amour pas de référence football
au
Qatar est à découvrir sur votre chaîne
Youtube un cœur tu as MLB faire appel et
à la fin du clip vous annoncer justement
la la sortie de votre deuxième EP alors
il est sorti le 11 décembre 2022 quels
ont été vos ambitions pour ce nouvel EP
en fait voilà ça a annoncé ce projet et
bah ça faisait en fait j'ai fait exprès
de sortir ce deuxième ep7 k82 deux en
jour pour jour après le premier donc le
11 décembre 2022 et c'était très
important parce que j'ai vraiment
évolué depuis le premier et il y a
vraiment énormément
de travail derrière et c'est un un
projet très très éclectique c'est pas du
tout que du rap là le la partie qu'on a
d'écouter c'est très égo trip mais dans
le projet il y a de la pop il y a des
morceaux dansants des morceaux très
personnels des morceaux qui peut qui
peuvent parler à tous donc j'avais
vraiment envie de de marquer de marquer
l'esprit et de dire que voilà corta est
là avec une vraie identité musicale
alors finalement justement kurta c'est
quelqu'un qui parle de lui mais qui
parle aussi des autres et aux autres
c'est exactement ça moi j'ai vraiment
comme je disais de part aussi mon métier
et j'ai toujours eu cette petite fibre
entre guillemets sociale et je trouve
que la musique c'est magnifique pour
pouvoir partager des émotions et c'est
important c'est un peu une thérapie je
pense chaque artiste utilise l'écriture
pour eux pour parler de soi et pour
voilà peut-être
quand ça va pas trop utiliser l'écriture
pour aller mieux mais c'est aussi je
pense un moyen de parler aux gens même
aux gens qu'on connaît pas et en fait je
suis sûr qu'on a tous des ressemblances
je rappelle que donc votre clip la Coupe
du Monde au Qatar est disponible sur
votre chaîne Youtube curta MLB votre
deuxième EP donc cette k82 est sorti le
11 décembre 2022 il est disponible sur
toutes les plateformes digitales merci
beaucoup kurta d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensation on peut suivre votre actualité
sur Facebook et Instagram que retard
tout simplement et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]